[Musique]
il vous faut autre chose comment aller
au cottage de belles bergdahl est gentil
propriété d'accord vous arrivez des
états unis je parie qu'il ya une
histoire fascinante derrière votre
voyage
quand j'ai perdu mon travail et mon
petit ami à san francisco j'ai essayé
gagner un hôtel vous avez gagné un hôtel
en nouvelle zélande et après un vol de
treize heures jusqu à auckland et trois
puces différents je suis désolé je
paierai s'il ya besoin de réparations
avec ça c'est pas très bon pour les pare
chocs
je suis propriétaire d'un hôtel de
charme ou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais faire confiance à une photo de
profil sur internet vous avez vous avez
vu un fantôme
gilbert c'est un petit futé vous
connaîtriez pas quelqu'un en ville qui
fait des rénovations jacques delors
vidal et son numéro et jack c'est quoi
ton numéro faut quoi tu en as besoin
c'est pour elle pas dit mais pourquoi
vous voulez mon numéro suis venu vous
faire une proposition
c'est une vraie beauté si vous voulez je
peux vous aider à le remettre en état
sérieusement tu vois c'est trop vieux
cette entrée qu'en fait les vieilles
maisons j'ai toujours été un passionné
de construction ça m'aide à me sentir
disons qu moins cassé donc j'ai
l'impression que les célibataires les
plus en vue de beechwood dams a un petit
faible pour vous une vraie beauté
oui c'est clair non
oui
la liste yade tirage devine quoi j'ai un
job parfait pour toi
vraie vie maths en chemin que tourner
oui j'ai oublié votre vraie vie tu sais
ce que je crois moi que tu lui a pas dit
ce que tu ressentais pour m
régime que l'univers un plan pour chacun
d'entre nous je préfère croire que ça
c'est bien qu'il
je croyais qu'on était ami
[Musique]